[Applaudissements]
il ya des fléchettes
attention les chéris vous avez deux des
trois fléchettes chèque celui qui fera
le meilleur score partira à las vegas
mais je rajoutais draghi a on va faire
que deux fléchettes et joyce et jeanne
mas vont jouer si joyce mais jamais
mariée avec lui dans sa ré d'avoir les
bras en vue de vous marier mais voilà on
verra l onf ont une aussi c'est ça elles
feront de fléchettes chacune six joyce
ou jeanne gagnent elles choisiront qui
par audard de fléchettes pour hui elles
sont deux façons normalement elle
devrait pas poser une fléchette chacun
qui veut démarrer entre et noah je suis
là oui entraînements les matches aller
on redémarre il suffisait d'un peu de
temps a dit maman adore alors vous avez
deux fléchettes et nohra on fera les
pieds dans la tension est ce que vous
voulez
[Applaudissements]
il mord et là en plus il sait encore est
2e fléchettes pour hydrater savoir il
mort derrière la celanese et garhyane
satisfaire mes pieds au peso peu calmé
boulade
voilà c'est pas nous c'est un nul il est
pas nul
il ya 6 et 8 6 contre 5 voix la sisqa
qu'un jeanne mas et au filet après josh
tire à sa fin ça je sais pas faire
graver rihanna ou attention j'ai gagné
il ya marqué las vegas est ce que
quelqu'un peut venir chercher jacques
masson attention deuxième usage d'enora
ce sera votre dernière flèche pas que tu
es né un fils mathieu est tout près tu
aurais eu d'annoncé du rail se seraient
battus tout près de vous il n'a qu'à
points à wil a qu'un seul bon allez on y
va ou tir après jones a lâché un drama
ce truc là y'a quand même là haut mais
il ya un mec derrière qui donne terrain
un gars comme ça qui la rend plutôt
honneur d'accord que la quoi qu'il
arrive si toute la chaîne faisait gagner
à buenos aires a pas reçus à la maison à
part si vous faites un safari gate
égalité attends je comprends pas égalité
de points mais a décidé d'aller aller
s'il vous plaît on y va attention
attendent
il a mordu oui mais je mords pas là et
regardez là ou non
aretz te plaît alors jeu las vegas
[Applaudissements]